here's a reaction in London to Donald
Trump's recent visit
yeah I could watch that forever those
are some seriously fit protesters they
couldn't punch their way through a cat
sneeze so here's more
[Applause]
no wonder they're worried about America
leaving NATO it's now you can learn a
lot from the protests first if there's a
violent revolution from the left we can
relax I have seen thinner corpses second
you can look it up but I doubt you saw
this kind of rage over the organized
child sex abuse and wrath room or recent
terror attacks in England third you have
to ask why they care so much about us
and about our immigration concerns it's
because these protesters are leftist
first Countryman's second as with all
socialists the cause always outranks any
patriotism but one of the giant Trump
balloon the media made it seem so huge
but I think I won something like that at
a County Fair twenty thousand pounds
that's what it costs for these idiots to
feel good about themselves meth is
cheaper and I hear more effective that's
the problem with trying to inflate your
importance without actually being
important at all you end up looking
small stupid weak look like a close
match
so Trump landed on that Island it became
the only thing anybody talked about he
made Sacha Baron Cohen look like mr.
Rogers did you even realize Wimbledon
was won and then he left
yep he came out of the sky scared the
natives met the Queen now he's gone and
they're all saying did you see that in
other words Trump went to Britain but
all you got was that lousy balloon so
although the blimp wasn't for Trump it
was for people who hate Trump it was
their therapy bet that looked like the
follow-up to Revenge of the Nerds don't
you tell me it's like a girl I bet you
can't say that there are some girls who
can hit have you watched the anime yes
you know the thing about Trump's
unpopularity it is visceral yes and you
see it in our country yeah most vividly
it's not it's even worse than Nixon it
really is you know I'm the only probably
the only one I definitely don't know
when old enough to know that firsthand
but there's a there's a kind of
metastasize hatred that is explosive in
many ways and I think the the normally
passive
polite brits i got a you know showed the
same kind of reaction that many many
well half the American electorate feels
so it's a he just generates really
caustic response but you know I noticed
Dana
it's often very childish and that's okay
you can protest any but I've talked you
this about when I lived in London during
Katrina people in pubs would come in and
jazz rail again I mean they were vicious
about bush they hated bush they beat
everybody that's on the right that's on
the right also I've never understood why
they care so much about who our leader
is way cuz we don't care about Michael
be like some deep-seated thing and like
we beat them so many years ago yeah so
the other thing is whoever the President
of the United States is he is the leader
of the free world and there is power in
that and they have this former glory
right thank you okay you said the Sun
never set on the British Empire but it
that's pretty early now now the balloon
blocks the Sun Jesse and the balloon
people might be on waters world this
weekend we stay tuned really we're
making a very hard effort to book them
this brings up a few questions for me
one if if Germany starts bombing London
again and Trump has to swoop in and save
them for the second time I think it'll
be pretty popular
second of all Trump gives weaklings like
this guy a purpose in life gets them off
their couch gives him some exercise some
sunlight on their face they get to be
around people with common interests and
I think that's a good and healthy thing
also I don't want an American president
to be popular in Europe I'm suspicious
of that Obama was popular because he
went over there and he claims you know
kissed their you-know-what and he
acceded to all of their wishes signed
all their little treaties and that's
okay but Trump is wants to represent
Michigan not Britain and that's fine
Kennedy it wasn't like the protest was
about war because it's like again Trump
is the like the opposite of a war monger
right and yet so what are they mad about
they're just mad about the man they are
mad about the man they're they're mad
about him and his temperament and his
personality but with a lot of people in
this country it's funny because we know
independent voters and those who maybe
believe maybe getting a grunge vote
they're getting used to them and that's
what a lot of people say and that's why
you know the loudest reaction comes from
progressive because that's the the
shrinking outrage
and the rest of the world will get used
to them almost when it's too late it's
going to be in the seventh year of his
presidency when they realize they're
going to miss him when we have another
bland vanilla monotonous president who
is a long-winded and very boring and
press conferences are you talking about
my pants
I'm so glad you said that because when I
saw those people punching yes the
president dummy and you know the guy
with tiny arms knocked him over I
thought oh okay he's not president what
do you want yeah is it in pentas exactly
actually the opposite of what most
people want pence is way more
conservative than Trump that's for sure
all right way less pragmatic oh yes